يملك لبنان 10 بلوكات البحريه لكنه توتال
لم تحفر سوى في بئر الاستكشافيه واحده تقع
ضمن البلوك رقم 4 حتى الان حينها اتت
نتائج مخيبه اللبنانيين ولم تتمكن توتال
من اثبات وجود مكمان غازي هذا كان في عام
2019 وكان على توتال بحسب العقد ان تبدا
الحفر في بئر ثانيه لكن العمليات توقفت
لاسباب السياسيه
المتحده الضوء الاخضر للشركات للحفر من
جديد
البلوك العق 4 حفره توتال يعني نحن هنا
بلبنان كلها المياه كلها بلوكات
ب100 عميقه جدا يعني مبين ال 1600 متر عمق
لل 200 متر بقى حفره بنقطه كانت عامله انه
يلاقوا فيها غاز ما لقوا فيها غاز ليه
اوفيا يا اللي نحنا بنقول له مجريشن جاز
يعني غاز متنقل عم بيرو- عمته لا يروح
ينحصر بالمكمل في اخر شيء الغاز دائما
بنقدر نطلعه بس ما همم
ولذلك
[موسيقى]
يعني اقتصاديه
في الى معنى نطلعه لليوم يعني
بقطاع النفط ما فينا ناكد انه في قبل ما
نحفر يعني كلها في كثير مؤشرات ايجابيه في
مكه من يعني مبينه على المساحات الزلزاليه
ثنائيه الثلاثيه الابعاد انه معقول يكون
في غاز بس لا نتاكد كقاعده ما فينا قبل ما
نحفر بئر استكشافه لان اكيد انه في غاز او
ما في غاز بالنسبه لكميه الغاز ولا همم
همم قيمه هذا الغاز ما فينا من هلا نعرفه
اول شيء بدنا نكتشفه بس صار في كثير
دراسات ودراسات كثير شديه اول دراسه
عملتها وزاره الهمم الماليه بلبنان لتشوف
قديش هذا القطاع بيجيب لضرايب وفي دراستين
جديه عملتها انجي او همم اسمها لوجي يا
اللي جايبه خبير انجليزي وقدر قد ايه
معقول ينتج لبنان او مثلا همم الحقول اللي
عنده اياها بقى
الارقام اللي بينت معهم الدراستان كانت
زيت الارقام تقريبا الارقام كثير كثير
متواضعه ما في شيء من الارقام اللي عم
تنزت بالسوق حاليا صحيح يعني همم باحسن
الاحوال
دولار بالسنه اذا كذا حقل كان عم بينتج
يعني هذه حصه لبنان عم بحكي حصه لبنان
اللي هي تقريبا النصف
حصه لبنان لا تتجاوز اا مليارين دولار
بالسنه على 15 او 20 سنه
اكيد انه قطاع النفط ما بيحل شيء من
الازمه الي نحن فيها يعني نحن لا تجي اول
دولار بعد عشر سنين ليفوت اول دولار على
الصندوق السياده من هلا لهونيك اذا ما مضى
من لبنان مع ال اي ام اف ما في بدنا بده
يضلل الناس الناس مكمل وبدها تضل الناس عم
تخسر مصرياتها وبده يضلل اقتصاد